no
oh we get white vision
okay so that's how they're playing it
well i'm just gonna have to kill him
again
does that mean paul bettany is fireworks
with himself
you paul bennett a silver surfer oh my
god
welcome back to new rock stars one
divisions
big mystery cameo might be paul bettany
he is he's such a jerk
the vision or jessica wanda
the i
of course it's him of course it's it i
love paul benny when i say he's a jerk i
don't mean it
but it's him of course it's him and he
he got us all
he got us all he's he's the new agatha
that's sneaky man
hey this is inside marvel this is our
one division after show i'm eric voss
here with
jessica clements how are you feeling
after episode 8 jessica
baby it was a lot to take in it was a
lot to take in for comic book people
there's so much stuff happening that you
had to like re-watch it to like write
down
every every scene of wanda's flashback
was like
okay well i gotta get my notebook out it
was it was a lot to take in this episode
uh more so to me than the others i was
like this is a lot of stuff
a lot of callbacks yes it was uh because
jessica
episode 8 finally gave us some context
uh we learned for sure that agatha is a
salem
witch who overthrew her coven uh we
learned that wanda created this hex
on the grounds of a home that vision was
heartbreakingly building for her in
west view to grow old in uh and we
learned that these sitcoms are
based on the tv shows that she watched
for comfort
growing up throughout her life uh and at
the end of the episode
wanda is officially named the scarlet
witch but people got questions still
jessica and i are gonna explain this
whole deal with white vision in the
post-credits scene a lot to talk about
there
uh we also learned some new stuff about
agatha and we're going to talk about
what we can expect for next week's
series finale tomorrow will be my
in-depth shot by shot breakdown of all
the easter eggs you missed this episode
and uh yes i am wearing our new latest
obsession shirt an unusual couple it's
got secret augmented reality easter eggs
it's awesome and you can get one at
newrockstarsmerch.com
if you get this shirt you will get the
opportunity to
write in a custom shout out that will
appear at the bottom of
our inside marvel episodes let's see we
got a few
here lori ingham says will the twins
stay kids at the
end or are they going to be grown-ups
oh they just jump to be an adult i don't
think they're gonna be in it
at all i think they're gonna get recast
maybe in a future marvel we'll
we'll talk about that uh augusta fellata
says steve german you're
the vision to my wanda except i would
have built west view in florida for us
oh it's sweet uh and then eric terry
asks what do you think of the cameo
or is the camera going to be gene gray
slash phoenix uh
the champion might just be paul bettany
himself paul benny as jean green
there might be another take on this
there's a lot
to break down we should stop saying
there's a lot to break down
and break it down yeah and yes we are
simulcasting this
live on stereo you can get this app for
free and follow us at stereo.com
new rockstars if you're listening to us
on stereo now be sure to stick around
for the end because we're gonna do a
bonus segment in which we're gonna react
in real time to the voicemails that you
guys send us
jessica let's dive into it what's the
big
wtf this episode wtf is the white vision
so this is
everybody wants to know because people
that haven't read the comics
are probably like oh he's just white but
it's more than that
it is more than that okay so white
vision is from the vision quest arc in
the 1989 west coast avenger comics which
is a very big deal
for several reasons so i'm gonna quickly
run through it um it
starts this is around when wanda and
vision are living in a new jersey town
in the 80s
uh and then at some point a
time-traveling villain called immortus
dismantles vision's body now fun fact
immortus is actually later revealed to
be
nathaniel richards aka kang the
conqueror but don't worry about that
just yet it's one of these weird
wait i was this uh and i was retconned
as this and
i will be retconned from this 3000 years
from now
just get ready it's awesome just get
ready um
so after he gets dismantled the avengers
and hank pym gather the parts of vision
to try to reassemble him
and they want to use the brain waves of
this guy wonder man simon williams who
was involved in an earlier plot
involving the grim reaper to transfer
visions consciousness
but they can't do this because that
previous process
ripped out williams soul so that plus
the damage to visions tissue results
in this white soulless vision form he's
not evil he's just kind of there that's
just what vision is now and what's fun
about this jessica is
originally vision dates back to like a
golden age era of marvel comics in the
40s where he did have a white form
and uh they wanted to reboot him and as
a member of the avengers in 1968
uh and they were going to keep that
white ghostly complexion
but stanley's like no let's make him uh
red
and they still they still make him white
in so many different issues
they're like right so they they end up
coming full circle with that original
incarnation of them
that storyline the one that you just
recited of like
he is basically like gonna be a not like
a soldier but like he's just like a
robot robot now
but there's also like he goes through a
different
dimension or a different reality and
takes the body of another vision
their white vision has so many
capabilities or not like
capabilities of vision but like he can
do the mcu bringing him into this
he there it's limitless and i know that
we say that a lot of these episodes
because magic is limitless but like
white vision is literally just a walking
computer
that has no emotional attachments to
anything
and if he can go into realities that
means he can just like take things
and now yeah a sentient weapon so now
it's just like
baby yes that is uh
jessica's exactly right eventually that
is how vision kind of gets restored
after this era in the comics he gets a
body from another dimension as jessica
said and then they um
he uses the brain waves of a deceased
scientist named alex
slipton and then uh simon williams brain
waves merge with those and that restores
vision's empathy in his soul
so he does kind of go back and forth in
different various forms
from that point forward it's kind of
like what part of vision
is vision here uh he's either a
disembodied ai
voice coming through speakers or it's
his body being used for some other
purpose
so many ways and then bringing in the
nathaniel richards is just like
oh gosh where are we going where are we
going with this
well let's let's look at it jessica in
terms of the mcu what they
seem to be doing so in one division we
find out hayward
has built his own soulless weaponized
version of vision and he
it looks like actually tried to do some
reverse psychology to trick wanda
into using her magic to resurrect him uh
but uh they end up getting her to do it
uh
kind of like what am i thinking what's
the reference point here of like
oh uh we got your thumb prints on this
can of soda that we brought you in the
in the witness room or you know in the
interrogation room uh they tricked her
using that residual magic
on the drone for episode five did they
know that was gonna be the
did we we were talking about this on
twitter and by we me and some people
but so did um and also shout out
to i think is jaywright jaywright he is
very smart and we talk it through on
twitter
but so did he know did he know that he
needed just
a little bit of wanda's magic in order
to re
remake vision or was that whole drone
idea just like oh well we have some of
this magic might as well because also
this might be a stretch why do you just
take it off of monica's clothes
why didn't he take it off something else
that went in there so that's why i was
like a little confused because i was
like where did that
mention get brought up in the show he
needed wanda's magic
to bring vision back together because
her magic is derived from the mind stone
which is what is now missing from
visions corpse to
uh bind all of these pieces together uh
and
what made it different uh that drone
different from monica's clothes is it
still had that red sorcery magic
coursing over it
it hadn't just been warped and changed
wanda seemed to put a permanent
hex on it to keep it from being
weaponized from there forward
uh to kind of trap that drone and stasis
yeah and somehow using some probably
gonna be
unexplained method they just scraped
some of that off into a petri dish
and then like stirred it up and then
poured it on visions
he licked it and then spit it into the
corpse i just imagine i'm like sucking
it out like it's venom and just
like spitting it and being like okay it
works now
and i'll believe it i'll be like oh that
makes sense
i think the implication jessica is that
hayward had been trying for five years
yeah okay that's true uh to reanimate
vision's body but that's why
why were they like just starting to do
it the moment
uh the moment wanda showed up at sword
i think that was all a show because
notice how careless they were super
sloppy they were slop down
the way they were pulling apart that
body they were just like hey we're like
world-class uh um technicians and he's
like nah just grab the the power saw
that you bring from home depot
just go to town on this corpse because
we need to put on a show to piss her off
hayward's a very smart villain in that
respect of just being like
you guys let's just bring in the woman
like i can start it all let's bring in
the source of sadness like let's bring
in the person most attached to him
and see if she can somehow do something
so
maybe it was just trial and error right
heyward's like is she still out there he
saw her on the monitor she looked
through the monitor that was a cool
moment
and then uh he they originally directed
her to where hayward's office was
uh she just didn't wait for them to buzz
her in but uh
that to me tells us that hayward
wanted wanda to steal those vision
pieces
uh he was disappointed when she left
without them because that might have
been why he sent monica
up there in order to try to connect with
uh wanda whatever wanda was doing
and then he could complete his mission
of getting wanda's magic
outside of that hex to you know sprinkle
it on his vision pieces
yeah just to use literally get some
sprinkles and put on that cupcake of
pieces i i and i spotted this when we
did
um one of our inside marvels where we
saw the recording of her walking in
there i was like
why is no one reacting to her walking in
literally everyone's so calm so she
didn't break into nothing
and hayward is a fool
but yeah it was he definitely wanted her
to steal it because why would you let
the strongest woman like basically the
strongest avenger
i'm sorry if you guys don't agree with
me um literally walk into this place
that's just separated by glass
i was like i this makes zero sense you
wanted her to take it so you could find
some sort of like connection and he
wanted it so much that
uh in episode five or whatever that was
he basically said oh i was cleared to
show these security tapes
and he lied to monica presumably some of
those sword agents in that room
knew that also was a lie they knew that
wanda did not successfully leave sword
facilities with visions corpse
so it really was just a lie on monica
which
comes back to that question monica must
already be a kind of superhero that's
why they had the security protocol when
monica first walked up
they know she's at like an almost an
avenger level power
uh and i i think hayward was like okay
i'm gonna throw an avenger and an
avenger see if one gets knocked out kind
of like curling
out of this hex so i can get some of
that yummy yummy magic
so i get some of that a hay word and
that's
so i'm still confused and i know that
people come here for answers
hayward it just has to be like he just
hates superheroes
he just hates he hates superheroes that
is right he can't be like
ultron no he can't be like mephisto or
something he just
literally hates i think he hates
superheroes that he can't control
uh the kind of classic government uh
agent the government leader
let's talk about this because it seems
like they're
adapting that comic but they're leaving
out some of the some of the comic-y
characters so
it seems like they're leaving out a
mortise they might bring in some version
of wonder man or the grim reaper
but some people are wondering is hayward
uh
either the grim actual grim reaper or
the actual
ultron or is he kind of like inspired by
these other figures
uh in his character saw some logic and
what ultron was trying to do with vision
or maybe like in the comics what the
grim reaper was trying to do with
vision's corpse that's just what
hayward's character motive is
oh yeah he's not gonna put on a hood and
grab a scythe and zap people with it
no no no no no but yeah i could see that
yeah that could be true but i also think
that'd be so
close to the narrative that it'd be like
you guys you can't trick us like this
disney can't do that you can't be like
so i think he is just
hayward a director that me too is
starting a beef
as a human i hate that's what i hate the
most is i'm like
you think money can save you against
like against scarlet witch
uh the scarlet witch but i think he is
just a human that's
being a butthole well and jessica i
think hayward is going to be
a bit of an audience surrogate because i
think up until this point
the average casual viewer of the mcu has
underestimated scarlet witch's power
because these past years age of ultron
infinity war they only gave us a glimpse
of what scarlet witch should be able to
do
i mean even uh agnes agatha seemed to be
surprised by
everything uh juan has been able to do
and i think the price that hayward pays
is going to give us a very clear
indicator of what one is capable of
moving forward and multiverse of madness
like this person can rewrite reality can
create a multiverse like don't mess
around with her
very content as a fan of scarlet witch
to finally be like okay we are getting
scarlet witch we are
really getting into wanda maximoff now
it's gonna be so much fun at one point i
thought
that um agatha was gonna be helpful i
was like
oh maybe she is gonna help her find her
powers and then later on i was like oh
no she she just wants to know how she's
doing this
she's just curious she's like what's
your secret she's like a neighbor asking
for a recipe for brownies yeah what's
your secret the entire time i was like
wow she's like
like a witch version of dr phil cause
she was just like
making their relive this trauma on
camera and i was like will you stop
she's gonna make wanna apologize to her
mother like yeah she's gonna be you're
gonna have to go to boot camp if you
don't learn how to treat your mama waste
with some respect and juana says that
okay so jessica let's talk about this
did bethany just
just troll us with this big cameo he
said this is an actor
with fireworks i mean if this cameo is
himself
like what a what an idiot of course he
did
and the thing is we fell for it because
this is something called bentley
does it is hook line thinker period
paul bettany behavior of being like yeah
he's the best guy in the game
it's himself i love him so much but oh
my god we were we wrote an
entire episode around who we think the
cameo is gonna be and it's paul
unless it's hank pym i was thinking for
a minute yeah because
uh worked on ultron in the comics and
was
an ultron created vision in the comics
so hank pym's part of that whole
um timeline because this is
after no and this in the mcu hank pym
isn't related
obviously i don't think but uh you're
gonna hate me for saying this jessica
and most of you i don't think that cameo
is paul bettany or maybe paul bentley
was referring to himself
in these interviews i think there's
someone that's someone else i think it's
himself
we're going to get that epic battle
that's going to be really cool but it's
also going to be sad because they're
both going to die
we're looking at a white versus red
white vision versus red vision
um which is interesting so jessica you
think they're gonna die
i think they're gonna be kind of evenly
matched i think
what's gonna happen is uh vision soul
is gonna get merged back with that body
at some point in the future and vision
will get to live on and that's how
they'll
they'll bypass his death and bring him
back i was thinking
that the red vision would win and then
the hex will
also kill vision along with it because
they're using a fraction of scarlet
witch's magic
to like re and like remake the white
vision whereas
this vision in this world is completely
her magic
so she utterly is stronger than the
white vision textbook
fact she's fighter fightier
than the white vision but um i was
thinking about that too but then if
that's the case then what's the case
with the twins then
they would have to bring the twins in
the world that's why i was hoping with
the storyline with the twins are like
when they do inevitably whoo vanish
maybe we get that original storyline of
their souls go into the babies
of billy and tommy somewhere else in the
world yeah she's playing god
well i think this is gonna be a tragedy
for for wanda but like
we're not done with billy and tommy and
the mcu i i
would be surprised you know they they're
gonna be young avengers so clearly
their souls whatever they are is gonna
have to get reincarnated in some form
somehow and i i think something like
that will happen with visions
uh essence as well the vision one will
be so close
not so close if you want to find me go
ahead to
the um oh my gosh uh
zoe saldana in um
gamora and yeah gamora that storyline of
just like
yeah we brought her back but she doesn't
know who she is would you assume that
the white vision when they merge with
the red vision
would also lose his memory or do you
think he would because it's like
because we're already seeing that
currently with vision i think this will
be
rebooted vision with his memories but he
won't have wanda i think their
relationship might be done
i don't think we're running through the
full depth of a relationship
some beautiful dialogues made these
characters how much more is there to
explore
in west coast avengers i think it was
west coast avengers there's so many
versions of visions life in wandas
um they do split up so this could be the
split up because after white
vision they split up and then he becomes
the other vision in a different costume
in the green outfit
so that could be this that would be so
close to the comic book storyline which
they have kind of not been doing they've
just been going on their own tangent
but that could potentially be the thing
that'd be so sad to watch them break up
like go through all of this and then
break up though would be kind of like
like i'd be hey that's how you keep that
will they want the energy alive right
you gotta bring people together
you gotta keep oh now we got another
freaking thing to worry about they're
not going to end up together
they're not going to end up together you
guys you just reminded us that this is
based on the west coast avenger run and
i think that's significant jessica
because
white vision firmly locks us into
west coast avengers i mean they've
referenced all kinds of different comics
they've referenced to tom king comics
uh it seems like they've done a bit of a
house of m but
the west coast avengers run the most
famous thing from that
is this whole thing with mephisto agatha
tommy and billy so uh that all goes down
while vision is white vision
and look people are gonna hate me for
sticking
on this mephisto
i owe it to all of you i have to go down
with the ship
if this is not the case it's going to
take the l
uh keep playing look playing in the bay
that ending moment there jessica she's
holding those two boys tethering them
around their necks
with hand in hand is that not similar to
a marionette the way those two boys were
puppeted by
master pandemonium in the comics
yeah i get it also like
she was she's also like a powerful witch
i i don't know if we're gonna get into
this later
or we probably will but her magic
different from
wanda's magic and how her magic is
slightly the same as dr strange's magic
fight me
um but fight me um but
i just think she and also the she knows
the kids aren't real so i think she was
like i'm just going to choke these kids
with some power
i'm going to choke these kids with some
magic i get where you're coming that's
the thing
if she knows the kids aren't real why
it's that's a performative thing that
she's trying to manipulate wanda's
feelings right now
when really these kids mean nothing they
are imaginary and she is putting on a
show of hurting them
why would she do that you know and all
these other clues we've gotten unleashed
hell demon spawn you know it's
really there for people are like oh this
episode makes it seem less like mavisto
i'm like honestly i feel like we're
exactly where we were the past
if anything i was too attached to the
fact that she turned
a cicada into a bird and then threw the
bird into the rabbit's mouth
and i was like yeah there's something
weird with this rabbit and we are not
the rabbit doesn't just eat birds
rabbits are herbivores
herbivores or herbivores jessica
can't pronounce her right that's a big
that rabbit guys we still have a lot of
the history there with what that rabbit
is who is ralph
like that's why i think there could be
some other cameo coming i think
that i think the rabbit is something i
think yeah we go back to the rabbit
tangent because i think the rabbit may
be something because rabbits don't just
eat birds
but also even if the rabbit was just
like oh yeah if someone was a play like
throw it over their head and be just
like it's yeah it's a demon rabbit
like of course he's bird i'd be like but
it ate a bird like it's
not it's not just a demon rabbit those
will just come lying around it's
it's it's mephisto no i think uh
i mean okay actually we got to talk more
about wanda after
the break real quick um but i'll just
say right now
if you're still on the mephisto train no
shame choo choo
i'll be conducting this train right off
the cliff i don't know one way yeah one
way
to get off a cliff i have to i just
think the evidence is still there
it's as much there as it was last week
it's still pretty weak evidence i'd say
but it's enough it's enough there and
there's still enough out of an hour i
respect you because if it turns out to
be a festival i'd be like damn i even
turned away from it
like i was even like i don't know
anymore
you cowards ready to leave one station
too
soon before we get to the gates of hell
we're so
close why are you backing out now vaz
has just gone insane
i totally have i've lost i've been
insane i've been insane since the first
trailer for this show i'm like wow
there's gonna be a devil in this am i
okay my um
my um whatever is what i for i'm losing
sentences i don't know words anymore um
the things for
that you put drinks on top of coasters
yes thank you
i said cooler um my coasters are hexagon
shaped
and i started going insane i was like
[Laughter]
like every time we record i'm always
like am i a witch
am i part of it am i in the show yeah
who am i am i playing jessica
am i jessica that does a podcast on the
hexagons
yes that would be man that would happen
yeah
all right we're going to keep talking
about this but first we want to thank
some people who helped us make the
episode starting with our friends at
audible so audible is the leading
provider of spoken word entertainment
all in one place at audible you can find
the largest selection of audiobooks from
bestsellers and new releases to
celebrity memoirs and a lot more they
also have original entertainment from
top celebrity creators and thousands of
popular
and binge-worthy podcasts unlike this
podcast that is a cringe-worthy podcast
these are binge-waiting it's not just
audiobooks folks they also have uh
podcast guided wellness programs
theatrical performances
a-list comedy and exclusive audible
originals that you won't find anywhere
else
of interest for new rockstars fans
audible has audio versions of some of
the greatest comic story lines of all
time
including the dark phoenix saga craven's
last hunt planet hulk
we've referenced these in a lot of our
videos you gotta check these out
i really like audible for some of their
original podcast content they have a new
show called the history of sketch comedy
that's how uh jessica and i met we're on
a sketch team together history sketch
comedy is hosted by
keegan michael key sketch lavas sketch
lavas
um yeah so this king of michael key
one's great they also have another one
called shootout it's about the infamous
1997 north hollywood bank robbery that
inspired the movie heat
among other things that took place uh
not far from where i live and jessica
lives
but we won't tell you exactly where us i
was walking my dog the other day and a
guy kind of gave me a look and a nod as
i was going to my apartment i'm like
oh damn it they know where i live
[Laughter]
i'll die for me when mephisto's not in
this i'll give your address out on
twitter later today everybody tune in at
3 p.m
and with audible membership uh you can
download titles listen offline
uh anytime anywhere the audible app is
free and can be installed on all
smartphones and tablets
listen across devices without losing
your spot new members can try audible
for free for 30 days visit audible.com
one division or text swan division to
500 500 again that's audible.com
division or text one division to 500
500. i want to thank bluetooth for
sponsoring this video so uh bluechu
is a unique online service that delivers
the same active ingredients as
viagra or cialis but in chewable form
and at the fraction of the cost that's
right you're gonna get some pop-ups by
popping these
um so blue chew tablets
ah i'm sorry it's just
there the fruit hangs so low
the plums
tablets
that was a good one i loved it i'm here
for it it was very fun for me
so bluetooth tablets help men gain that
extra confidence for when it is time to
perform blue chew is an online
prescription
service so no visits to the doctor's
office no awkward conversations no
waiting in line at the pharmacy it ships
right to your door
in a discreet package sign up at
bluechew.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you'll receive your
prescription within days blue chews
licensed medical providers work with you
to find the right ingredient in strength
for your prescription
and bluetooth tablets are made in the
usa and they prepare and ship direct so
it's cheaper than a pharmacy
so if you could benefit from a bit of
extra confidence when it's time to
perform visit bluetooth.com
for more details and some important
safety information and we've got a
special deal for our listeners try
bluetooth free when you use our promo
code one division at checkout just pay
the five dollars of shipping that's
bluetooth.com promo code wandavision to
receive your first month free
and we thank bluetooth for sponsoring
this episode
and also stereo we know
uh you have a lot of questions and a
whole bunch of theories about this
episode we're gonna be addressing them
in a bonus q a segment
that will only be on stereo this morning
so
as we said before jessica and i are live
on stereo as we record this stereo is
the live podcast app that allows
you to react uh to questions and
comments in real time
you submit them to us we listen to them
we play them on the episode
and you hear us talk to you in real time
it's like a phone call with the world
uh or it's like the best of uh live
call-in shows
uh all kinds of madness is happening um
this is a telethon every
uh so our bonus q a with stereo
listeners will actually end up going up
on the youtube channel on sunday so if
you want your questions featured
on youtube but if you missed it this
week just be sure to join us next week
at 8 am
starting next week we're gonna be on
stereo every weekday
five days a week uh in addition to
making daily and double daily videos on
youtube we're just gonna be very very
busy and there's gonna be lots of ways
that you can
hear us and talk to us it's gonna be a
very exciting week
and weeks going forward uh so download
the stereo app right now if you haven't
already follow us at stereo dot com
slash new rockstars click that link in
the description again that's stereo.com
new rockstars all right jessica back to
our next wtf
i literally like started crying at that
joke i am obsessed
it's so now i'm going by it just for the
joke everyone should be buying blue chew
for
bosses yes one line joke yes for that
alone
okay oh my god
okay let's get into this stop popping
one
okay so wanda wtf
was agnes's backstory why was she more
powerful than the other witches in salem
which
okay you go first
uh okay so an interesting thing she is
the daughter of that other witch
uh she called her mother that's evangel
yeah i think is the name harkness
um and they say you stole magic above
your agent station you practice the
darkest of magic
uh and then she says i didn't break your
rules they simply bent to my
power i gotta say jessica i love this
opening because
i thought it was going to be the classic
salem witch trial where they drag a
witch they tie her to a pole and then
they force her to confess
um but no it was a witch-on-witch trial
like that is so freaking cool
like how messed up is this which for the
other members of the coven to turn on
her
uh and you didn't notice until they like
did the magic of the chains
i was like oh [ __ ] it's like they're
witches too i was like damn
that was awesome and ruthless yeah uh
it seems like she as the daughter of
this uh
of the leader of the coven that she
maybe had
access kind of like the uh the kid on
the football team who's the son of the
coach and can peek at the playbook
before practice
is that a thing i was never on a
football team i just assumed that
i can tell look i can tell i can't i
could completely say i was on baseball
teams and the
coach's son tended to be at a nice
convenient place in the batting order
uh i wonder why that makes more sense
but he wasn't cheating
looking at a book of plays the truth is
i would be terrified i would hope that
my name wouldn't be on the batting order
i would do that math i'm like okay well
if every one of us strikes out it means
i will only have to be up at bat
two or three times this game i hope
that's it and then the rest of the
team's doing great i'm like damn it you
gotta base it that means i gotta go up
to bed and i'm gonna be the third out
uh i hated playing baseball as a kid
love watching it hey i can tell
um so i think uh
agnes slash agatha must have been some
kind of exception to the rule of this
coven it's implied that these are
witches from salem but 1693 they might
have been able to
slip away from those trials means these
are some badass [ __ ]
and agatha is most badass of them
um i think she had some kind of innate
power she might have been the scarlet
witch of her generation the most
powerful witch
well and then she feels threatened by
seeing a new witch they can do stuff she
can't
that's why i thought her mom was the
original scar or not the original but
one of the scarlet witches because of
the crown on her head when she had the
powers i was like oh this looks just
like
scarlet witch's crown yeah i but
when i saw it i was like i was like uh
the powers and then when i rewatched it
again i was like oh
this is definitely like she was a
scarlet witch and i thought at first she
was absorbing their powers but she was
just retaliating their powers right like
they were shooting at her she was
reversing the shooting back at everyone
else
tenfold so i was immediately like okay
her mom's a scarlet witch i think
okay theory i think agnes wanted to be
the scarlet witch i think she tried so
hard to like get more powerful by
probably working this is also a question
how
and i'm sorry for not knowing this was
the darkhold already made
on wondergore or by the demon by now
because i was like what if she was just
reading the book
and that's what the mom was like we
don't read this damn book
damn book yeah it's supposed to it's
just like
the seashell bowl that everyone has in
my bathroom she was like don't look it
don't actually touch it it's not
actual seashells this candy ball is for
guests it's like well no guest ever eats
this
it's like we don't have guests it's for
the guest
screaming at you i'm like okay so
i was like questioning that because i
was like what if she was up at wonder
gore or whatever
working with the demon and they were
like
girl we don't work with that demon we
don't do that mess down here why are you
trying to
get involved with the darkest of magic
that's like straight up the devil
well some people are pointing out the
fact that her purple
colored magic which theirs wasn't purple
theirs was kind of this blue color
with a bit of orange uh poking off it so
purple implies like
a connection to dormammu or the dark
dimension right that she could have
gotten her powers from this other
dimension
so it means maybe dormammu could i mean
dormammu just had like
you know a mocap face in a doctor
strange
but like there are other forces in the
dark dimension uh
it could be caffon or it could be
nightmare or something like that
nightmare usually has the color green
associated with him uh or it could just
be as simple as i don't know if she was
firing off that energy to me it seemed
like they were she was draining it
like the way that thanos uh had like
the tethers wrapped around him on titan
and then he kind of used that and
shifted his weight and threw everyone
down it seemed like
agatha was doing the version of that
that she was using that uh
that goofy looking spell harry potter
without the wands as
josh and i were joking about before uh
to kind of
suck their life force out of them
turning them into these kind of lifeless
husks
which so if she was draining their
powers was she also taking
them was she taking the powers of like
seven witches
right i yeah i do and i think that's
what made her
capable of standing up to her mom at the
end her mom stayed out of it because she
she wanted to be like at the execution
line the one soldier who has the blank
and their rifle she wanted to not have
her hands dirty by executing her
daughter or draining her life force away
and then once she was able to overcome
all these other witches
evangel was like crap uh all right i'll
try to take her down
and then at that point she was too
powerful it backfired
she's also obviously taking her powers
from evil because she was like
mom i can do good and she was like no
you can't
but what is committed to a that was such
a weird line it's like
witches don't want to be good it's like
i can do good i'll be a good witch as in
i'll only
uh kill like virgins who walk in a
graveyard at night
they're like we don't want to do that
weird
love crafty and [ __ ] do not bring
that in here there's shades of morality
within which law
like i don't think they care yeah
they're they're like what is wrong with
you that's not good
um i also think by good she meant like
because i feel like
her mom and the other witches were
probably not harming just innocent
humans
maybe i i don't know i don't think so i
think they were kind of just doing which
stuff with
herbs um with herbs what if i said with
her
i started saying it right when i'm
talking about actual plants um
but i think they were just doing magic
with normal stuff um which made them
seem dangerous
but like uh agnes or agatha would have
actually done harm to people
she was like i just think her her whole
justification is like she wants to be
the most powerful she wants to know
everything
because she was like yeah i learned this
it took me years it took you 10 minutes
it took me like
a millennia it took you an hour she was
like how are you doing this
she just wants to know everything she
wants to
which kind of doctor strangey look
you're trying to
keep going they're the same person
shut the hell up or harry at the spot
you know or nancy drew jessica but
whatever i want to interview the whole
world
and i want to know everything um and i
want to know it all
yeah i think uh yes so you got to
imagine what are these witch's goals
versus what was agatha's goal
to me it seems like these witches just
want to live in secret and
do their own little devil worshiping on
the side where she's like
no uh i want to use this power to
dominate the world
and i want to like rewrite reality in a
way that i can based off of these
secrets i've learned from the dark
dimension why aren't we going the next
step
and they're like honey you're going too
far with this we're trying to just fly
off the radar
truly and if they're in secret she's
just straight up like why don't we go
big
and it's like girl i don't want to get
killed at the stake
like i'm not that powerful and she's
like i am and i'm like well good for you
you go out there leave me out of this
you go out there then
you go fight the humans like i'm staying
right here in salem
i want to ask you jessica uh wanda the
[ __ ]
is pietro then is he a projection i
believe
agatha called him a crystalline uh uh
possession
yeah or is he a transmutation that she
also showed she was able to do
shape-shift animals into other animals
and also why evan peters
why fm peter's that's a loaded question
first off i think he's just i don't
think he's i don't think he's a
projection i think he is a transmutation
because you can physically like touch
him and do a bunch of stuff with him
also she's using him as a vessel to see
and hear everything
so i feel like you need to be able to
have like an actual yeah
she's a microphone and motor microphones
nouns and
so is he
[Laughter]
oh and a verb so um
i think i think he i don't think he's
just like a projection anymore more so
that she mutated him into something else
whether it be like a cicada
or something creative but she's still
using him as the vessel
um will he be which i think this was
maybe your question i don't know if it
was
you asked like five questions in one
he's not he's not coming into the
mcu yeah this episode
made it even clearer that it's not gonna
be fox quick i mean
this week kevin feige confirmed at a tca
event that
he's the quote was evan peters uh it's
it's just another way that certain
people
were messing around with wanda and based
on those words it seemed like
he is some form of magic that she is
using as her eyes and ears
but it's not something that she pulled
from the multiverse and the fact that
it's seven peters is just
a wink to the fans in which feige and
the rest of the marvel team
vastly underestimated how fans would
interpret
scene quicksilver from the box movies
show up in this well
again how dare you do stuff like that
knowing that your fans are gonna be like
digging like 20 feet into the ground for
information
but yeah i think he's just like and she
also mentioned like
i would have done your actual brother
but he's literally in a different place
like i couldn't do it that was kind of
the justification there but
then why not just another actor why evan
peters i think they're like oh we can
get him and peter
that's a joke yeah i think it's a joke
see i don't think he's a transmutation i
don't think i mean last week i was
saying that
uh the rabbit is going to be nicholas
scratch and the rabbit's going to shape
shift into evan i don't think so
uh you know i think i was wrong i was
wrong i'll take the l uh oh
he said it you guys record it one of
many times
add it to the list of uh what we got
wrong 2021. uh
no i mean look i made a lot of theories
uh within these episodes week to week uh
like
this wonderguard ever bloom thing i
don't know if that's gonna be the case
next week
are they gonna be i hope so but it might
not uh so
i was leaning towards it after the salem
stuff i was like oh
okay she must be going up to the
mountains to like work on stuff but it's
like the demons oh
she's just hanging out with the demon
demons i don't think she's good
um mountain goats and mountain demons
same thing
you guys didn't know this but the same
[ __ ] um but yeah i
i i don't know i don't think it's like a
foolproof theory but i was like
she's been getting her magic from
something darker whether it's the dark
hold and she's reading
the book like doctor strange um i think
they keep going back like doctor strange
um i think she
still is like i don't know i think
wonder
has something to do with it but keep
going um yeah i just think
like uh shape-shifting animals and
shape-shifting forms are part of her
powers i think singer scratches
something else
uh and we still don't know that rabbit
ate another animal rabbits don't
do that she talked to the rabbit the
rabbit said something to her
and i don't think that was just a joke i
think he said something there was you
know past times where she's like senior
scratchy his real star
potential yeah i mean now i'm swinging
back to the other side that he might be
old scratch this guy might be the devil
in some form he's old scratch
um if he was her son i would be so mad
i'd be like why is this [ __ ] scratch
why is he eating a bird
yeah i mean he's going to be i think the
rabbit's just going to be ralph
at the very least like that rabbit's
going to be called ralph's going to be
something else
we still don't know who the missing
person is we don't
no we don't and i think that's kind of
the big huh the big question mark
remaining
uh what is this rabbit is it ralph and
his ralph
nightmare or mepisto or chathan or one
of these other
demonic entities or is it some new thing
that marvel
cinematic universe is going to introduce
we still got one more episode
um but let's talk about jessica our next
wtf what are wanda's powers specifically
did she have sorcery before the infinity
stone yes that looks to be the case
yes she did let's
talk about it she did also the missile
was that
damn toaster these things are slowly
coming back now when that beeping was
happening i was like i'm gonna go
insane with this beeping and it's the
same as the toaster
same beep um but yeah she obviously had
powers and the
stone literally just like amplified them
yes
absolutely that looks to be the case and
so now the question is was she she must
have been born with these powers
does she have the mutant gene why do i
keep
wiggling this thing i need like
something to hold i need a pen i have a
spoon over here no it's got no clue
i don't want to flick it around stop it
all right
the word milk is triggering yes
how dare you i'm lactose intolerant but
sorry um
it's okay i just can't have milk or ice
cream or pizza or good things i can't be
happy
so um sorcery and x-men
let's talk about it so there is
potential that she could have the mutant
gene like
this could be the introduction to the
x-men she could be right
it's got to be but
it like they clearly were like chaos
magic like they
want to shove in our face that this is
mcu right well
chaos magic is in the comics like those
two things aren't set yeah well they are
separate but like
in the comics one is both a mutant who
also has chaos magic yeah
that's kind of what her mutant ability
is but in the end
in the cinematic universe can we do they
differentiate
i hope that's one of my well here's what
i think i think they're gonna
tie monica and wanda together this way
because it's clear that
monica had powers before going through
this hex wall
she was strong she had some kind of
durability something happened during the
past
i think both of these women had a mutant
gene i think that's
even though monica rambo's not a mutant
in the comics i think that's a simple
fix
as a simple retcon just saying she's a
mutant and her powers are similar to
captain marvel you know she can um
absorb energy
she can see the elect she can turn into
a wave of light essentially
um but yeah i think that's going to be
something that brings these two together
is the fact they were both born with
these powers and they were both exposed
to radiation that amplified those powers
absolutely i think especially with that
scene of like
the scene the stone and she saw herself
as god yeah that's our next question so
what do you think that was
what did what was that i immediately i
immediately saw it and my first reaction
was because in one of the comics her mom
is a scarlet witch
and so i was like oh it's her mom but
then we saw her mom
and i don't think she's a scarlet witch
in this series in the cinematic universe
i think she's just a normal mother
um a normal mother without superpowers
irina
i think she literally the stone was like
this is you and then instead of wearing
that outfit she put on a trench coat
jacket
just went around and wanda maxim off but
i think this
is them being like you this is you
deep down this is you you know you have
something you survived
two days in rubble with a bomb you
obviously did something to survive that
with your brother
um so i think it was her but at first i
immediately was like oh is it her mom
i was like it's her mom she came back to
tell her she's like that's stuff i like
that
i like that interpretation jessica i i
think what this was is
uh a glimpse to the future of uh wanda
seeing the
we're gonna see the mcu version of the
scarlet witch in like a full scarlet
witch costume
if you look at the poster you can start
to see pieces of what that will look
like
it's gonna be a dark dark crimson color
uh it's not gonna be that bright red
halloween costume it's gonna be
something that looks cooler and might
have a version of that magical tiara
that we saw on
agatha's mother but what i like about
this jessica is it defines
wanda as a sort of nexus being from the
beginning actually described her as
a myth but she could kind of see into a
future i think not only was she looking
into a future in that moment that was
showing us an
alternate reality it was like our first
glimpse into the multiverse of one to
seeing an
alternate version of her and that kind
of set the stage for
in the finale episode i think we're
going to start to see her come full
circle with that moment
and and build out the multiverse as her
yes yes
awakening 200 200
210 good job gold star i love it i'm
here to do it
i'm reading into it yeah all of them
completely agree haven't
oh there you go you have them at your
destination yes just prepared
this is not broken but um i agree i have
nothing to say to that uh
nothing doesn't counter it that's it i
love that we look ahead to the finale
jessica
our our uh next wtf what's going to
happen in this finale
yeah how is one efficient final episode
going to link us to spider-man uh no way
home
multiverse of madness what's the how's
this battle gonna play out
it depends it depends after having this
talk and me liking the idea of white
vision becoming them separating
but we still have vision we still have
wanda they just go fight different
battles and
eventually we'll come back in the end
but like if they are two different
beings and go do two different things
it can go into spider-man where we see
awanda
or like well ultimately i know that
wanda doing this power thing
ultimately disrupts everything else so i
think that's what spider-man will be
about is how like it disrupted that
but i do think going forward if we do do
this two separates we have vision
and wanda and they are separated which
hard to believe but it did in the comics
um they will go fight different battles
and what we'll get like kind of how like
carol danvers is rarely there we'll
probably get something like that
where it's like vision's there sometimes
or wand is there sometimes
wanda would probably be the one that's
there sometimes she's probably like
i'm done with this world she pulled in
manhattan and was just like
i hate these people and i'm sick of this
plan and i'm leaving for a little bit
but i think that would ultimately be
where it goes but
do is that 100 gonna happen probably not
because this last episode's so much
dependent on it
we still haven't seen where monica is we
like and now that agatha's there is
actually gonna stay there is she gonna
die
where is senior scratchy like there's so
much there's so much
there's so much yeah and i'll tell you
after the last episode
well i think uh i think you know there
was some thought that maybe
pietro and monica might team up from
that snooper's gonna snoop moment
i don't think so based off what agatha
said this episode it seems like he's
just kind of an incarnation of her magic
uh and that he'll get reassumed into
whatever
threat agatha is maybe team up with her
as they're trying to overwhelm
wanda i think um monica and vision
hex vision are going to team up to fight
100 yeah and then yeah and she's gonna
have to
envision the edge to overcome what i'm
saying i don't know how
she's gonna fight two people two
storylines she has hayward she has white
vision
she has agnes i was like i don't know
how she's gonna fight all three but yeah
they definitely are gonna team up
damn it's gonna be like sad because i
bet they're gonna fight white vision
succeed and then wanda is gonna be
agatha succeed and then while the hex is
going down
vision's running to wanda to be like
goodbye yeah that's what's hard sorry to
make everybody sad
the show is so many things at once it's
both like a story about like technology
and a story about witchcraft and magic
and obviously a story about like grief
which i think that's what i love most
about this episode
is just this writing uh this one line
that vision said
uh what is grief if not a
love persevering yes such a beautiful
statement
every once about the mcu really catches
you by the heart with these
uh with these lines it's such a human
moment that
uh that's exactly what wanda needed to
hear in that moment and you could see
what made her fall in love with vision
and that's what i was that's what i've
been missing from juan and vision's
relationship
up until this point in the mcu is what
made her fall for him and you can see it
in that moment vision's profound world
view was able to connect with wanda in
this beautiful moment
uh so i hope we get another moment of
that uh next episode cried
at the scene where she when she pulled
out that piece of paper i was like what
is that and it was like
real old here and i was like he bought a
lot of land yeah suddenly this is
pixar's up
and it's like oh it and then i was like
i was also like in my head i was like
girl
go off destroy everything in sight i was
like
i would go insane and then on top of
that of being like
i was also like the outer the left side
of my brain was like how did two of the
most powerful superheroes think they
could just
leave and live in the middle of new
jersey together
and be like we're like a happy family
and it's like you guys are the strongest
people
everyone's trying to kill you and you
need to save the world constantly yeah
but it was well i think as we look ahead
to spider-man uh no way home something
we'll be talking about a lot more
uh in the weeks and months ahead i think
at the end of the day this is going to
end with a kind of house of m-s
uh birth of the multiverse or an access
to the multiverse
uh and that's where wanda will escape i
think the kids may go with her she's
gonna try to find
some um other universe to try to hide in
and try to escape in and i think that's
gonna be her ending i think she's gonna
have to split up with vision
uh and he's gonna have to uh fight off
white vision to allow her to escape
and that's just how she's gonna do it so
that will set up loki
i think multiverse madness that kind of
stuff um but we have
i think one final what the devil segment
uh
and i wrote one down okay keep going
sorry am i using there's a different one
i could totally be wrong about mephisto
i understand uh but i have to go down
with the ship so i want to make a final
argument
uh for why i think mephisto might still
show up
because okay go ahead go ahead
go ahead give him your platform we start
this episode with
a salem witch trial but a different
witch trial which on which right
so in the language of this people are
saying oh they kind of sidestepped
uh some of the dark uh satanic elements
to a piece china no go check out me and
mt's
um big question episode they could
totally put in all kinds of dark
superstition stuff
in there they don't care about china
disney plus is not in china
and when it is they can simply remove
this title from it and not
care they can remove this episode they
can edit episodes uh so that it isn't
about
satanic stuff we talked about this
rabbit i just want to focus for a second
on the fact that they're speaking
in latin and i think that's a deliberate
choice
because latin is the association of like
ancient spells in our world
uh because it is a lot of this magic
is done in defiance of the roman
catholic church
uh it has a christian origin the fact
that they're saying they could
say any kind of weird made-up language
in that moment
they deliberately had them say latin
which i think
gives a kind of christian overtone to
what their dark magic is now
this rabbit it's still we don't know
this rabbit is gonna be something
he's and they call him senor scratchy
now if he's not her son nicholas scratch
we're back to the argument that he could
be old scratch
she said in episode two cinder scratches
got real star
quality don't you think uh he is a
carnivore which rabbits are not he
said something to her this rabbit could
and he was right next to the open
darkhold on the table
there's something with this rabbit we
know that this is tied to the west coast
avengers storyline and sure
they're going to leave out plenty of
elements from the west coast adventure
storyline they're only adapting pieces
of it
but the most important thing and this
isn't just like what were the nerds are
pulling up some obscure comic issue and
making a case for it
every time in the past when uh elizabeth
olsen has done uh a press for who the
star
which character is she's like i'm gonna
go back and explain who
uh scarlet witch is in the comics for
all you marvel fans
she brings up this whole storyline of
her kids being pieces of mephisto's soul
that is so important to scarlet witch's
journey uh
and that sets up house of m uh it
like mephisto has gone an important
character in the mcu in so many ways
uh or in the marvel comics in so many
ways and
they said unleash hell demon spawn you
know there are all these clues in there
and these aren't just throw away visual
clues like the grim reaper helmet and
the animated intro
these are lines that characters say and
they're lines that the writers have to
know the meaning of when they put it in
there
and then finally i you know when she has
these tethers around these kids
throats like if she knows they aren't
real
why is she so worried about threatening
them if not for it being a
show a marionette show a puppet show and
it evokes that moment of past
master pandemonium puppeting the kids
with his hands
i think these kids could be pieces of
mephisto's soul they're gonna call him
mephisto
explicitly in the episode it's one thing
maybe it'll be implicit
just something we could interpret from
it but all the evidence is there that
they are
definitely being inspired by that moment
of mephisto using fragments of his soul
to manifest children that are tricks uh
to manipulate wanda
it's all there uh how far they wanna go
to spell out
this rabbit or that there's someone in
the shadows but
ralph there's a missing person we don't
know what this rabbit is he's something
and it's gonna get revealed in the final
episode
he said his last he said it he said it
last here
i rest and we will learn next week that
is tonight
he will go in the next the next episode
will just be me and
john cause just went off the ramp
he ran away he ran away to new jersey
man people are rooting for me so hard to
be wrong uh i get it it's funny they
they are if i backed out at this point
if i were to say before the show was
done
actually i don't think so i would
disappoint far more of you
i have to go down with the ship true
because i definitely jumped off
i literally got in the dinghy you're
staying playing the jello
i said nope i was billy zane i took the
kid and i jumped in the boat i have a
child
i have a child it's a child i stole a
kid
got in that boat whereas meanwhile i am
uh in a string quartet with
uh mephisto and the grim reaper and
nightmare saying
should have been it's been an honor
playing with you tonight yeah
for some reason you guys started playing
the cantina song
[Laughter]
this ship is going down there like damn
this is good that's
good music this is great well that is it
for this episode of inside marvel or one
division after show we're gonna be back
next week with our reaction to the
finale episode we're gonna see how right
and wrong
all these theories are uh it's what a
ride
yeah we should just the entire hour just
write down what we were wrong about
there's gonna be a lot of uh
now we uh stick around on stereo we're
gonna start answering your questions uh
it's going to be like the after party
for the after show be sure to download
the stereo app if you haven't already
stereo.comrockstars
uh we're doing new shows every day of
the week i think starting next week
again just thank you for joining me you
are such the perfect co-host
uh calling me out of my [ __ ] giving
me theories i didn't think of
you're so great it's so funny and so i'm
sure you could find anyone to call you
out on your [ __ ]
but you do it in a way that doesn't make
me feel bad oh never
i'm very i'm i'm here for critiques i'm
like your
fourth grade teacher i seem a little
disappointed but i'm not
but i'm not i have a bad way of showing
it
follow jessica at lulu underscore
clemens on twitter and then lulu clemens
on instagram and other places follow me
at eavos follow new rockstars subscribe
to inside marvel wherever your podcast
we're gonna close with our favorite
moment of the episode where are my
children
where are my children
[Music]
you